Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Yesterday morning we discussed the three
basic times in which prayer is
prohibited. Now when we say prayer is
prohibited, we are speaking about
optional
extra prayer.
Prayer that is not the obligatory prayer
of the five daily prayers. We're not
talking about the
the two and four and four and three and
four respectively. We're not speaking
about those prayers. Those prayers are
to be made as immediately as a person is
able.
If a person sleeps through a prayer, if
a person forgets a prayer and then
remembers this prayer during the these
times,
they are to make the prayer immediately.
These times don't apply to that. So in
this narration of that we discussed
yesterday and before yesterday
in which he tells us that the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
used to prohibit us from praying and
burying our dead during three times
throughout the day. And he said at the
when the sun rises and when the sun
sets and when the sun is at high noon,
these are times when optional prayer is
prohibited. But obligatory prayer, this
doesn't apply to that. And this is
actually a common mistake, probably more
common than you would expect.
A person would wake up during sunrise,
having missed the clock or what have you
for fud. They wake up during sunrise.
They see the sun is rising.
And so they say, "Well, now that the sun
is rising, we have to wait 20, 30
minutes before we can make salah because
salah is prohibited during this time."
Incorrect. This does not apply to the
obligatory prayers. Our prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam says,
He saysam,
"Whoever sleeps through a prayer or
forgets it, then he is to pray it
immediately upon remembering." There is
no other
experation or anything that can take its
place except for to actually make that
prayer. A person when a person wakes up
late
let's say they set their alarm they
intend to wake up for fudger
they intend to wake up on time
but they miss it
and so then they wake up
halfway through sunrise
we know
starts at the break of dawn on true dawn
until the sun rise. Correct? That is the
time of fud for someone under normal
circumstances.
But if a person sleeps through a prayer
or forgets a prayer, the time of is not
that the time of for that person is as
soon as they wake up is once they
remember. No matter when it is. Let's
say a person loses consciousness
and fails to make fud until 2:00 in the
afternoon. When is for that person?
2:00 in the afternoon. Exactly. Let's
say a person
has a surgery
and that surgery goes from
all the way to
they can make and early before they go
in. But if time is not in yet, they
cannot make. So let's say they go in at
11:00 and they get out of surgery at
10:00 and then they're in recovery and
sleeping, etc., and the drugs are
wearing off and all that great stuff
that I'm sure we've all experienced or
many of us.
And then finally when they come to and
they're able to pray at 7:00 in the
morning, what time is for that person?
7:00 in the morning that is the time
that they make and and
etc. The time for prayer for a person
under normal circumstances for fud is
the break of true dawn until the sun
rises. But a person who has forgotten
when is the time of prayer for that
person when he remembers. A person who
is sleeping not purposely right but they
fall asleep or they're sleeping. what
time is for that person when they wake
up etc. And we will get to that later on
in the chapters. Today we'll take a
narration
on the authority of
now
or
so it is with the
companion came and accepted Islam in the
early days in Mecca.
But when he heard of the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam and came to Mecca
and found him,
he found him in the harshest
hardest time of persecution in Mecca.
And so he came and he accepted Islam and
he wanted to move to Mecca and be with
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. But he
said to him, "This is a very bad time
right now.
you will not be able to handle it with
us, especially as an outsider.
So go back to your land and when you
hear that I have established
outside of Mecca, then come to me.
And so he accepted Islam, returned to
his respective village. And then later
when about 10 years later when the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam made hij
and established himself in Medina who
walks through the doorbet
and he says do you remember me?
That's what he said.
You know the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam has been through
all kinds of stuff. He's met all kinds
of people since then. As a matter of
fact, since the time of Absah, he's been
to the heavens to meet Allah himself.
Right? So when Absa walks in and says,
"Do you remember me?" It's highly
unlikely that he would remember him.
Correct? He said, "You're the man that
came to me in Mecca."
They remembered him. And then the
prophet sallallah.aii wasallam proceeded
to teach him about the most critical
part of his religion and his worship,
which is salah. He said to him,
it's a very long narration actually. You
can find the narration in
he says to
He says, "Pray fud the morning prayer,
the prayer of the dawn."
And then refrain from praying after
what? After.
Refrain from praying
until the sun rises. until the sun rises
above the horizon.
He says,
he says, "Because when the sun rises, it
rises between
the two horns of a shan." And that is
the wording of a shan. What does this
mean? Does this mean that the sun is
rising between the two horns of El? No,
that's not what the narration says. So
in the time of Jahya, people used to
worship the sun. People used to worship
the sun and the most ideal time for
worshiping the sun when they would
physically pray to the sun is when it is
first rising and peaking above the
horizon. Why? Because when a person
prays, it is right in front of him. And
so they believed that this is the time
when the sun allows us to worship it.
That's why it's so low in the horizon
for us humans, us mere mortals to be
able to bow and prostrate to it.
And so they would pray when the sun is
rising. They would pray when the sun is
setting.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam prohibited the Muslim from
praying during that time. Why?
Because even though the Muslim's
intention has nothing to do with
worshiping the sun, the outward
appearance
still matches. Correct? An onlooker
could mistake their prayer for the
prayer of those who are worshiping the
sun. And if there is no distinguishing
feature between two actions except for
intention then if then this is
considered to be this is considered to
be imitation rather a person intends it
or not. So the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam prohibited the companions from
this. We will continue this tomorrow
[Arabic recitation]